là où ça bouge nous sommes ce soir au
théâtre d'hérouville à la comédie de
caen non pas pour parler de théâtre mais
tout simplement d'une très belle
exposition de tristan jeanne vallès à
voir jusqu'au 30 juin
qu'ils s'appellent les ombres portées
une exposition à voir dans le cadre de
normandie impressionniste 35 ans de
travail notamment en noir et blanc
pour tristan jeanne balès un photographe
de caen commençons avec cette photo
d'eux j'aime bien est ce qu'au centre de
manche je suis assez fier on va dire
parce que c'est donner ce qu'on veut et
puis on cherchait de faibles taux
recommandé la photo a été publiée par le
monde
le lendemain c'est un vieux monsieur qui
vient saluer qui est ému qui salue toute
la salle du châtelet qui vient de
l'ovationner
donc il ya eu il y avait tout ça non non
non ce moment là
on s'est retrouvé embarqué d'un shoot
cache tout casser en république d
macédoine dans un mariage gitan avec
musique fanfare couleurs alcool en fait
tout ce qu'il fallait c'est une photo de
rue ils ont ces photos de fêtes c'est la
musique des gitans
on ne photographie pas la musique on ne
peut pas c'est impossible je
photographie les gueules leur guerre les
échanges de regards et doit serrer son
instrument les mains qui claque la
salive sur le bois noir de la flûte
d'accord de frapper et la foi ni mallet
percussions tout principe aussi du
portrait c'est toujours un jeu à deux
c'est à dire que si la personne en face
me donne rien c'est pas facile pour le
photographe d'arriver à une belle image
poursuit vraiment il faut qu'il ya un
minimum de complicité
même si même dans les portraits sur
commande qui peuvent être un peu
artificiel je dirais pourquoi est devenu
fou demain vous le savez aujourd'hui
pourquoi je suis devenu photographe
parce qu'un jour on s'était en irlande
justement j'étais dans le jeu des
musiciens déjà et donc je voulais être
photographe et à un moment je me suis
dit mais c'est pas que je veux être
photographe ces jeux s'ils photographe
à partir de maintenant je le suis
et après les choses se sont enchaînées
j'ai travaillé qu'une agence bosser pour
des journaux comme libé comme le monde
tout ça j'ai beaucoup fait de photos de
théâtre aussi enfin les choses se sont
enchaînées à quel moment c'est parce
qu'on le dit parce qu'on le sent parce
qu'on le veut enfin je sais pas moi
c'était il ya 35 ans je suis toujours
photographe donc je me dis que j'ai eu
raison
une exposition textes et photos à
découvrir jusqu'au 30 juin au théâtre
d'hérouville
l'entrée est libre
passons maintenant au rock'n'roll riff
raff tribute to ac/dc samedi aux
soupapes de comines
en attendant retrouvons stéphanie et
jean-michel pour un concert demain au
bbc
là où ça bouge on va vous parler de
chansons sans frontières on vous en a
déjà parlé c'est un concours d'écriture
de chansons des textes en français c'est
un concours international aussi et
demain c'est la cérémonie de remise des
prix c'est la soirée de clôture de monde
je suis avec jean claude meurisse vous
est à l'initiative de ce projet qui a
dix ans désormais la soirée de demain
revenant d'abord à ça de quoi il va
s'agir là c'est les 10 ans de chansons
sans frontières on a adonné à un nom qui
nous est venue comme ça la nuit des
atomes crochus c'est on espère
rassembler des gens qui ont des liens
entre eux qui ont des affinités convient
de faire la fête
et puis on est très heureux d'accueillir
sanseverino qui était notre invité ya
dix ans c'est un artiste qu'on adore et
je pense que ça va passer un moment de
grosses fêtes avec sherazade en première
partie amélie delaunay charly venturini
beaucoup de surprises beaucoup de
surprises en cette soirée
on découvre des gens de 90 pays dans le
monde qui savent parler notre langue
certains presque mieux que nous et qui
écrivent des chansons donc c'est une
merveille sa et recevoir des textes
d'afghanistan du cameroun thaïlande par
des gens qui écrivent des chansons en
français je trouve que c'est une
merveille
donc c'est une langue de partage en fait
alors rendez vous pour à la fois
découvrir ces textes mis en chanson pour
le concert de sanseverino
on l'a dit pour aussi votre concert avec
sherazade c'est au bbc et c'est à 19h30